i'm sarah schneiderman i'm assistant
professor of anthropology and south
asian studies at yale and i work in
nepal himalayan parts of india and also
in the tibetan autonomous region of
china i'm a socio-cultural
anthropologist
i've been going to the himalayan region
for nearly 20 years now i went for the
first time in 1994 as a college student
and i was studying anthropology and
religious studies and was just
fascinated by the diversity of cultural
and religious practices and the way that
they intermingled and the dynamic nature
of social life in the region i've been
at yale for nearly two years now and i
teach in anthropology as well as in
south asian studies i've been involved
in building up the south asian studies
program here particularly in my current
role as director of undergraduate
studies for south asian studies
and i've also been involved with the
yale himalaya initiative since its
inception i've been serving as faculty
coordinator and just doing a range of
playing a range of different roles to
help bring speakers into campus and to
really build up the profile of himalayan
studies at yale i first went to nepal as
a college student as i mentioned and i
was very interested in studying religion
particularly buddhism and hinduism
and as i began to become more interested
in those topics and began to spend time
in different parts of the country living
mostly in rural village areas i started
to understand that actually most people
and i would say that anecdotally most
people in nepal
actually have some sense of one of the
other countries nearby have either spent
time themselves working or in education
in india or perhaps china
particularly the tibetan autonomous
region many people are spend time there
for trade or other kinds of
livelihood occupations and so i became
increasingly aware of the fact that even
though
looking from a kind of american or
western perspective we often tend to
think of the himalayas as a remote and
isolated location actually many of the
people who i was working with in these
remarkable
locations were in fact very cosmopolitan
and were spending time traveling between
multiple different countries doing a
whole range of different things so i
actually followed the people who i began
working with in nepal
to their work sites particularly in
himalayan parts of india and darjeeling
and sikhim and also into the tibetan
autonomous region of china across the
border to the north and what i found was
as i was trying to understand
livelihoods and ethnic identity for
people who were living in rural nepal
that it was absolutely impossible to
understand what they were doing and why
they were doing what they were doing
without also understanding something
about the broader regional configuration
and their own experiences of mobility
across borders
mobility across borders in the himalayas
is actually a very long-standing feature
of livelihoods for many many people
these days we often tend to think of
cross-border migration or mobility as a
feature or a consequence of
globalization but i would suggest that
actually for this part of the world
that's not the case at all and in fact
many
historical trade routes depended on
mobility across what we would now see as
nation-state borders whether between
nepal and historical tibet or between
nepal and india also looking further
east for instance between india and
burma burma and china and then in the
west of course between nepal india
kashmir pakistan i'm using the
contemporary
nation-state names but the point is that
historically many people have been very
very mobile across this broad region and
livelihoods have often depended on a
combination of subsistence agriculture
which is of course necessarily rooted in
one place
but that's complemented by different
kinds of trade or wage labor which in
fact depend upon mobility my doctoral
research which i'm now turning into a
book focuses on these processes of
cross-border circular migration for one
ethnic community called the thang me and
i look at how for the thang me
cross-border circular migration is
actually intimately tied up with
processes of ethnic identity formation
so usually ethnicity is talked about
within the framework of one nation state
or it's talked about as somehow being
deterioratorialized or transnational in
this day and age but i argue instead
that actually the experience of being in
different states and the different state
policies that people encounter has
significant effects on the way that they
conceptualize and also enact and express
ethnic identity and their very sense of
themselves
it's been very important to me to
maintain an open and continuous dialogue
with the people with whom i work
particularly members of the thang me
community in relation to my doctoral
work um
and to make sure that what i'm writing
about them actually reflects
as accurately as possible what they
think about themselves now this is a
challenging proposition because they
don't all think the same things about
themselves and this is one of the
large points that i try to make in my
book that just because people share an
ethnic identity doesn't mean that they
all think that ethnic identity is
produced in the same way or is
meaningful in the same way so one of the
big issues i have to deal with is a very
diverse community actually spread across
several different countries
and with very different kinds of
educational and class
positions so what you end up with is a
situation in which certain people would
like to control the types of things i
write and ask me to write one thing
instead of another and my position has
always been well i am actually trying to
represent the community as a whole and
that requires sometimes having competing
and contradictory voices in there when
we think about the himalayas as a unit
of analysis i think what's really
important is to on the one hand
recognize the constituent nation states
that make up the himalayan region india
and nepal bhutan china pakistan
probably others that i've missed out
so to recognize
the specificity of those nation-states
the kinds of policies that they apply
the effects that those have both on
people and on the natural environment
but at the same time to look at movement
across those boundaries and to
understand what connects them so i think
one of the most promising
aspects of the looking at the himalayas
as a focus of as a new kind of area
studies is in fact to do both of those
things at once